this is microsoft surface pro while it
looks incredibly similar to surface RT
it is noticeably heavier and thicker
like surface RT surface pro is
compatible with Microsoft's touch and
type covers it has the same built-in
kickstand to prop it up but surface pro
also has two built-in fans and a venting
strip that runs along the top back edge
of the device it does get incredibly
warm with use but the fans are quiet and
nearly imperceptible in most settings
this is a Windows 8 PC through and
through surface pro runs on an Intel
Core i5 processor and overall
performance is speedy and smooth more
importantly you can run all of your
legacy Windows apps and freely install
software from the web you can definitely
use surface Pro's your main and only
computer just know it's not a great
tablet or a great laptop but it is the
most compelling and unique portable
windows 8 hybrid we've used to date